Guten Morgen Stefan. Ja, wir stehen noch davor.
9.33 Uhr.
Zunächst mal, bevor ich das vergesse, ich habe von einem Hörer von Niklas eine Nachricht erhalten, die sich sehr gefreut hat über die Aufbereitung zu den Schnelltests und der sagte, es gibt da ja das Video von Mighty Nguyen Kim vom August.
Richtig.
Und da sagt sie, da hat er nochmal drauf hingewiesen, ich habe es mir darauf nochmal komplett angesehen, könnten Schnelltests ein Gamechanger sein? Und die Antwort lautet Ja. Sie zeigt, wo Problematiken noch sind. Vieles ist auch inzwischen schon ganz beseitigt. Darauf hast du ja auch dann hingewiesen. Aber sie sagte Ja, die könnten Gamechanger sein im August. Also auch jetzt haben wir eigentlich alle Namen parat. Trosten, sogar sogar eine YouTuberin, die Merkel in ihrer Bundestagsrede unglaublich gelobt hat. Und so schön, wie sie das sagt, könnte ich das niemals sagen. Ja, aber offenbar hat sie nicht zugehört.
Ja, es ist ganz dramatisch. Ich habe mir gestern auch noch mal Merkels Fragestunde mit den Familien angehört, wo sie so durchgehetzt sind, wo sie quasi, das werde ich dann vielleicht im Fernseh-Podcast-Automaten vorbei, wo sie quasi auf alle Einwände, die so kamen, hinsichtlich, liebe Frau Merkel, mit meinen fünf Kindern, mir wächst die alles über den Kopf. Und übrigens, ich habe nur einen Computer für alle fünf und die Schule beginnt aber 8.30 Uhr für alle. Und ihr ständiger Verweis auf, vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein paar Ehrenamtliche, die wir hier aktivieren können. Oder auch sehr beliebt, vielleicht gibt es ja in ihrer Stadt noch ein Angebot, das sie nicht kennen, der Hilfe. Oder dann, als der Vater konkret meinte, also ich brauche echt noch mal einen zweiten Computer, mir fehlt ein Tablet. Und der meinte, okay, dann schaue ich mal, was ich da noch machen kann.
Und das war sehr schön, du hast nämlich auf Twitter darauf reagiert, denn das ist ja genau dieses Prinzip Subsidiarität, das ist ja das, was Helmut Kohl schon groß gemacht hat. Wir verlagern das jetzt mal alles weg vom Staat ins Ehrenamt und die loben wir dann auch einmal im Jahr dafür, dass die sich da aufopfern, Tablet machen oder was auch immer.
Genau, das Sommerfest des Bundespräsidenten für die Ehrenamtlichen jedes Jahr, wenn keine Corona ist.
Genau, genau. Und das soll es dann sein. Und du hast dann bei Twitter eine Rechnung gemacht, wie viel die Rettung der Lufthansa kostet und hast das mal geteilt durch die Schüler, die wir in Deutschland haben. Und dann stellt sich heraus, dass man für das Geld, auch jedem Schülern Tablet zur Verfügung stellen könnte. Und das finde ich sehr schön. Das sind sehr schöne Rechnungen, die uns auch zu einem Buch führen, das wir heute besprechen, nämlich das von Grace Blakeley, Stolen, in dem es ja darum geht, was dieser Finanzmarktkapitalismus uns gestohlen hat, dass man genau solche Rechnungen überhaupt nicht mehr in der Politik machen will, sondern lieber schaut, machen wir dann auch den Shareholder Value glücklich, wenn wir jetzt die Lufthansa oder sonst was unterstützen. Und mit solchen Rechnungen kann man eigentlich sehr gut immer zeigen, ja man müsste das mal umverteilen und dann ist genug für alle da.
Genau, sie hat ja das große Argument, das ist ja ihr Antrieb einmal aufzuzeigen, wie man das, was allen gehört, einmal so durch die Politik durchschleust, dass am Ende nur noch Profite für wenige da sind. Und ich habe sozusagen die Rechnungen andersrum gemacht, wenn man jetzt die neun Milliarden für die Lufthansa nimmt und durch zwölf Millionen Schüler teilt, hat man 750 Euro pro Nase. Und das reicht nicht nur für ein Tablet, sondern auch noch für ein paar Schnelltests. So dass man vielleicht auch mal wieder zurück in die Schule könnte, wie das zum Beispiel in Österreich jetzt praktiziert wird. Ja, es gibt wieder Präsenzunterricht, nur für die, die sich morgens testen. Testen ist so aufwendig wie Zähneputzen, findet in Deutschland immer noch nicht statt. Es gibt auch keine weitere Bemühung dazu. Man hat jetzt die Arzneimittel-Verordnung so ein bisschen geöffnet, hinsichtlich Schnelltesten möglich, aber es gibt ja noch keine zugelassenen und ich verweise noch mal auf die Liste der Bundesregierung. 330 Produkte werden dort geführt und sie haben alle ausreichend Spezifizität und Validität, dass sie überhaupt zeigen, was sie aussagen, was sie aussagen, wenn sie was aussagen.
Bevor wir reingehen, noch einen Gedanken loswerden. Und zwar erlebt man ja jetzt doch auch dank YouTube, dank der Möglichkeiten, dass jeder sich aufnehmen kann, den ein oder anderen Landrat oder Bürgermeister, der nicht im Fernsehen erscheint, manchmal aber dann auch im Fernsehen, bei Landsgab ist ja da auch entsprechende Szenen, die dann einfach mal selbst das Heft in die Hand nehmen und sagen, wir machen das jetzt so mit den Schnelltest oder wir haben das und das noch organisiert, dass es einfach besser klappt. Und wenn man die dort erlebt, dann merkt man erst einmal, ist eine ganz große Bürgernähe einfach dazu deshalb da, weil diese Leute die Bürger am Telefon haben. Das ist nicht wie bei Merkel. Einmal im Jahr gibt es mal eine schöne Runde und da beklagen sich jetzt mal eine Stunde die Schüler und die Eltern und dann ist man die wieder los, sondern die haben das eigentlich täglich vor Ort. Und da stellt sich mir die Frage, sollte man nicht eigentlich in Krisenzeiten, also es ist jetzt nur ein Modell, aber das ist auch nicht so leicht umsetzbar, aber sollte man nicht eigentlich in Krisenzeiten einen Austausch vornehmen? Also dann können ja mal Merkel und Co können mal gucken, wie das so an der Basis ist. Aber eigentlich müsste man sagen, jetzt lassen wir uns von Bürgermeistern und Landräten regieren. Wahrscheinlich wäre das besser, weil die wenigstens in solchen Krisen pragmatisch sind, weil sie das immer sein müssen. Das müssen sie sein, wenn ein bisschen Hochwasser ist. Das müssen sie sein, wenn irgendein kleiner Sturm ist, wenn irgendein Fest abgesagt wird, wenn es irgendein größeres Drama im Ortskern gibt, dann müssen sie immer pragmatisch agieren. Und da zeigen jetzt ja sehr viel. Wie pragmatisch sie denken und wie schnell sie dann auf kurzem Dienstweg was organisieren können. Und sie haben zugleich diese enorme Bürgernähe. Eigentlich wäre das jetzt interessant zu sagen, wir übergeben jetzt mal das Zepter den Bürgermeistern und Landräten und dann schauen wir mal.
Und zwar nicht irgendwelchen, sondern in Rostock regiert Klaus Ruhematzen. Wer ist das? Es ist ein Däne. Er bringt also klar deutsche Disziplin irgendwie, aber vor allem dänischen Pragmatismus mit, wie er bei Lanz jetzt kürzlich sagte. Und das erstaunliche ist, Klaus Ruhematzen ist gar kein Politiker, sondern der war bis vor anderthalb Jahren noch Buchverkäufer oder Schuhverkäufer oder irgendwas. Also er hat sich darum gekümmert, wie muss eigentlich der Laden aussehen, dass die Leute relativ viel kaufen. Dann ist er Politiker geworden. 100 Tage später kam Corona und dann ist er nach Kiel gefahren in die Nachbargemeinde sozusagen. Ist ja da oben alles, also ihr wisst im Norden halt, ist ja alles nah beieinander. Lothar Wieler vom RKI hat seine Runde durch Deutschland gedreht, um den lokalen Zuständigen zu sagen, was jetzt zu tun ist. Lothar Wieler hatte nur einen Auftrag an alle. Schmeißen sie die Bürokratie über Bord, tun sie, was sie glauben richtig, was richtig ist. So, Klaus-Ruwe Matzen fährt zurück nach Rostock, telefoniert schon im Auto, ruft alle seine Zuständigen an und sagt, wir müssen alles über Bord werfen, bitte denkt nach, was ist jetzt zu tun. Er kommt nach Rostock an, baut alles auf, fragt noch beim Land an, ja, könnt ihr mir mal helfen beim Schnelltesten, die sind so teuer, sagen die, ne, sie können es aber gerne hier einklagen, das Geld. Sagt er, ach, scheiß drauf, ich kauf die jetzt einfach so aus meinem Stadtgeld, stellt sich raus nach zwei Monaten. Klaus-Ruwe Matzen denkt, scheiße, wir haben ja hier Corona in der Stadt, was ist denn nur passiert? Bin ich ein schlechter Politiker? Dann guckt er einmal von seinem Schreibtisch auf und stellt fest, ganz Deutschland brennt, nur Rostock nicht. Er hat sich also über Wochen reingenerdet in dieses Corona-Thema, hat mit allen telefoniert, hat alles ordentlich gemacht und hat am Ende gedacht, eine Inzidenz von 17 ist viel, während in ganz Deutschland die Inzidenz über 100 lag und hat dann festgestellt, ich habe eigentlich doch alles richtig gemacht. Also solche Typen brauchen wir jetzt und es sind nicht nur lokale Politiker, sondern es sind auch noch Politiker, die erstmal neu in der Politik sind, die also nochmal richtig out of the box denken und wenn der RKI-Chef sagt, werfen sie mal alles über Bord, dann tut er das auch. Also in deren Sicht, da muss man nicht mit dem Argument kommen, das ist ja wie in Tübingen, das ist ja klein und überschaubar, Deutschland ist so eingeteilt, dass es überall kleine, überschaubare Einheiten sind und da kann man doch einiges tun. Und da muss man dann auch mal Jens Spahn ernst nehmen, der nämlich wiederum mit dem Lothar Wieler in so einer Townhall zwei Stunden lang zusammensaß, die dann auch wieder nur bei Phoenix übertragen wurde und auf YouTube keine Ahnung, wie wenig Klicks hat, wo er sagte, also formal juristisch hat der Bund gar keine Zuständigkeit in der Pandemie. Und ich habe mir so gedacht, um zu gucken, das wäre doch mal was, wenn man das mal ernsthaft angeht, dass die eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben, also zu sagen haben in Berlin und dann sollten sich alle mal am best practice mäßig Tübing, Rostock zum Vorbild nehmen und sagen, wir machen jetzt mal ordentliche Lokalpolitik. Hier in Frankfurt übrigens, ich bin zufrieden, läuft es auch sehr gut. In deren Sicht, genau, Corona beschäftigt uns hier, aber im Salon heute ein bisschen weniger. Ich habe jedenfalls nur einen spezifischen Corona-Text. Ich will kurz teasen, ich gehe die Zero-Covid-Initiative mal kurz durch, denn selten wurde Deutschland, glaube ich, so verführt von einer Idee, die gleichzeitig so gefährlich ist. Und Menschen, die das nicht gelesen haben, liegen mir auf Twitter in den Ohren damit. Und damit muss heute mal aufgeräumt werden. Wenn auch nur vor unseren 1804 exklusiven Salonmitgliedern, die wir jetzt gleich begrüßen.
Ja, ich möchte nochmal über Plattformkapitalismus sprechen, über den digitalen Kapitalismus, proprietäre Märkte, aber es geht jetzt nicht um Google, Twitter, Facebook und Co. Sondern um ein deutsches Unternehmen, Check24. Auch das ist hochinteressant und sehr, sehr ähnlich. Dann hatte ich schon angekündigt, wird es um einen Lebensratgeber aus dem 17. Jahrhundert geben, der uns sehr viel sagen kann darüber, wie wir uns besser in den sozialen Medien zu verhalten haben. Und wir werden mal ganz kurz schauen, was geht in christlichen Buchhandlungen so ab. Und werden nochmal darüber nachdenken, wie wird ein Glauben heute organisiert? Was bastelt man sich da so selbst zusammen? Darüber sprachen wir ja auch schon. Und wir fragen uns noch, wie wird man eigentlich ein Genie? Und eines habe ich noch vergessen. Es geht noch um Videospiele und um Filme. Und zwar war meine These ja häufig, naja, das Kino, das läuft jetzt ein bisschen den Videospielen nach. Das stimmt zum einen, zum anderen, aber laufen die Videospiele auch dem Film nach.
Sehr gut. Knüpfe ich nur kurz an das Genie an. Wie wird man eigentlich Genie? Wir vergleichen heute mal den Sachverhalt, dass es keine Biografie vom chinesischen Staatspräsidenten Xi Jinping gibt und dass es im Gegenzug eine ganz hervorragende Biografie über Barack Obama gibt. Und zwar eine, die er selbst geschrieben hat. Es ist unglaublich, wie diese Welt auseinanderfällt, wie die Systeme sich unterscheiden. Aber gut, gehen wir mal rein, verabschieden wir uns hier von der breiten Masse und sagen Hello, exklusiv, Clubhouse, Club, Club, Club, Salon. Gut, bis gleich Leute.
Bis gleich.